all right
everybody ready
one two three four we're good
all right good evening i'm lieutenant
ray spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting at the stratosphere hotel
casino
in the 2000 block of las vegas boulevard
the details that i am sharing right now
are very preliminary but at around
10 p.m tonight officers responded on
report
of a male shot in a hotel room in one of
the guest
towers what we have learned is that
there was a
birthday party that was taking place in
one of the hotel rooms at some point
individuals that appear to know each
other in the hotel room
there was some altercation and gunshots
were fired in the room
at that point several people who were in
the room fled we urge
anybody who was at the hotel in the room
or any witnesses that have any
information
please reach out to crime stoppers you
can do that anonymously and there's
reward money available if your tip leads
to the arrest and conviction
so again it's still very early on in the
investigation but with that i will take
a couple questions
are you able to confirm what floor
i'm not giving out the specific floor
right now
right now i just know it's a birthday
party we're trying to find out the
specifics
as far as we're working with hotel
security right now
and they are going through the
surveillance video we're still trying to
backtrack the suspect's movements
through the hotel
and fleeing the property so again still
too early on
tonight and into the morning we'll have
more answers
the deceased is a black male in his
early 30s he is deceased
at on scene all right thank you guys
appreciate it all right